Hi, everyone.
My name is Chris Broadfoot, and
I work on the Maps API and
Developer Relations team
at Google Sidney.
Unfortunately, it doesn't snow
here, but I can live
vicariously through
this year's Easter
Egg on Google search.
So this is just a quick
screencast to show you how to
use an awesome, powerful feature
called Styled Maps.
We released Styled Maps at
Google I/O 2010, but I wish I
saw it used more.
It allows you to customize the
look of your map's API map to
brand your map, like on this
store locator, or to draw
attention to some data you've
put on top your map.
Or it can be used to just
make your map a
little bit more festive.
To get started, I recommend
using the Styled Map wizard to
generate the necessary code to
produce your styled map.
The quickest way to get into
the wizard is to use your
preferred search engine.
When you load it, you'll see
some instructions, but I'll
just show you some of the
basics of this tool.
So first of all, let's navigate
to Sidney using the
search bar on the top right.
So styling uses two concepts
to apply color and
changes to the map.
The first is Map Features, and
you can see it represented at
the Feature Type panel
of the top.
The second is stylers, which
are found below.
These define color using a
combination of visibility,
hue, saturation, lightness,
and gamma.
So let's make this map a
little more festive.
First, let's change
the water to red.
I'm going to change the
hue, saturation,
and drop the lightness.
You can see these changes come
through straight away.
The labels are distracting a
bit from this really pretty
map, so let's remove them
from all feature types.
When I press the Add button,
I can keep adding styles.
Let's then make all of the
landscape green using similar
styles to water.
And as you can see, it's
surprisingly easy to create
cartographically horrible,
or just plain ugly maps.
Parks and roads are the main
thing left unstyled, so let's
make the parks green as well,
and let's change all the roads
to be white.
Just bring the lightness up.
So Styled Maps are available
both in the JavaScript API and
the Static Maps API.
We can bring up a static map
by clicking the Static Map
button, and you get a URL down
at bottom that you can embed
straight into your
application.
We can also press the Show
Adjacent button to get the
styles in adjacent array, and
we can copy these into our
existing map.
So I'm going to add an option
called Styles, and pasting the
styles we generated using the
wizard, and you can see
instantly that these styles
have been applied.
Styled Maps are really quick.
They're just as fast as
a regular Google map.
They're super simple, and
you should try it today.
See the documentation for
more information.
There's additional features like
custom map types, so you
can enable your users to switch
between the default map
and other styles
you've created.
Thanks for listening
and happy styling.